welcome to the man of recaps this is
cobra kai season four at the end of
season three long time karate rivals
johnny lawrence and daniel larusso
agreed to combine dojos to take down
cobra kai but with their wildly
different teaching styles there's a few
speed bumps and so johnny agrees to try
out some miyagido karate while he
teaches daniel his newly named eagle
fang and pretty soon these two are on
the same page their united dojo is
stronger than ever but cobra kai is
stronger too with their new star recruit
johnny's son robbie keane who was
seduced to the dark side by his evil
karate grandpa john crease remember
robbie spent season one learning miyagi
dough from larusso and now he's teaching
cobra kai their defensive techniques now
with his rivals teaming up john crease
recruits his old cobra kaiko sensei
terry silver he was the main villain in
karate kid 3 and was a coked up
ponytailed psychopath but now he's a
happily retired normal person who
doesn't want to join a teenage karate
war but chris pulls out his trump card
you owe me from when i saved your life
back in nam and pretty soon the karate
calls to him it's ponytail time again
and terry silver's back in cobra kai now
remember miguel and samantha larusso are
back together and for the first time in
the series miguel gets to spend some
time with her father daniel larusso
russo becomes a new mentor to miguel and
pretty soon he's embracing his miyagido
karate meanwhile sensei lawrence is
truly embracing his eagle fang name even
though eagles don't have fangs so he
brings the old miyagidos for some wildly
unsafe training to jump across these
rooftops sam's like yo dude you're crazy
but johnny's like hey you always want to
do the safe thing your dad wants for you
and this resonates with sam she's like
yolo and leaps across yeah a flying
eagle now daniel doesn't like his old
rival influencing his daughter and
johnny really hates that his student
miguel is looking up to larusso
eventually they decide this isn't
working out one of them has to step down
and the way to pick who is with a karate
rematch yes it's finally happening the
epic rematch this whole series been
building up to ya ya ya karate they are
evenly matched and in the end oh they
knock each other out at the same time
it's a tie these long time rivals just
couldn't stay friends for long and the
united dojo breaks up now it's not all
peachy at kobakai either sometimes terry
silver oversteps himself and undermines
crease priest has to lay down the law
remember soldier i saved your life back
in nam so i'm in charge now the teenage
karate rivalry still burns hot but it's
a cold war this season they've agreed no
fighting until the official tournament
but that doesn't stop them from hitting
each other in non-violent ways hawk
remember became a cobra kai bully but
switched sides back to the good guys
last season the cobra guys teach him the
price of betrayal they do the
unthinkable and shave hawks mohawk
without that he's just eli moskowitz
again he's lost all his self-confidence
and wants to quit karate but his best
friend dimitri gives him a pep talk like
hey man eli was pretty darn cool too and
so he decides he'll stick with karate
now joining miyagido but the biggest
karate feud is between the girls tori
nichols and samantha larusso after tori
literally broke into their house last
season it's mrs larusso who steps in for
the mom smackdown but she kinda
accidentally gets tori fired and turns
out she's working tons of jobs to take
care of her sick mother and little
brother so mrs russo feels bad now
you've got a tough life kid let me help
you and she vouches for her to get her
unexpelled from high school so now tori
tries to squash the beef with sam but
sam's not so forgiving she still hates
her now as if we didn't already have
enough karate rivals there's a new kid
in town this season kenny he starts off
on the wrong foot immediately gets
bullied by none other than larusso's son
anthony history repeats itself from the
original karate kid this time just with
new types of bullying so kenny gets
advice from his older brother who is
robbie's friend from juvie and tells him
hey find robbie keane he'll teach you
karate so robbie takes this kid under
his wing teaches him the way of cobra
kai and pretty soon he can stand up for
himself as for anthony larusso when his
parents find out he's the bully his dad
tries to whip him into shape but this
kid is just uh so eventually daniel's
gotta go into discipline mode no more mr
nice daddy and of course at the very
heart of all this conflict it's the
karate rival love square which is now
finally complete as all members are
dating each other's exes now tori and
robbie were not dating but they go to
prom together which ruins miguel and
sam's night and at the after party it's
couples karate yeah all in all a
fantastic night for these two and they
officially get together speaking of
getting together remember sensei
lawrence started dating miguel's mom
they finally tell miguel and it's a
little weird but johnny takes him for a
heart to heart where it's like yo kid i
never had a good father figure i really
want to be one for you but one night
when johnny's real drunk he's like i
love you kid but he calls him robbie his
real son's name oh that's rough now it's
almost time for the all valley karate
tournament and they're making some big
changes this year most notably there's
now a separate girls division this is
bad news for eagle fan karate because
they currently have zero girls so johnny
goes down to the high school to try to
recruit some teenage athletes but the
recruit he finds is actually from the
debate team it's devin lee who's a
natural-born eagle and so all three of
our dojos are training hard for the all
valley remember they had the agreement
whoever loses shuts down so now it's all
come down to this for the first time
since season one it's the all valley
under 18 karate championship the early
rounds all go as you'd expect the one
surprise is super nerd dimitri who's
gotten pretty good yeah his character
growth's hilarious remember he's still
dating the hottest girl in school hawk
still has a crush on his ex-girlfriend
moon but he's like without my hawk i'm
just eli but moon's like hey i like eli
better and eli's got his mojo back luck
of the drop hits robbie and kenny
against each other and kenny's gotten
real good real quick but darth crease is
like kill robbie no mercy and robbie
kicks him oh maybe too hard anthony
larusso feels bad for bullying him tries
to apologize but kenny's like yo it's
too late now i'm gonna be your bully and
robbie starts to realize i might have
led this kid down the wrong path now
eagle think karate still has a chance to
win because fighting for them is miguel
last year's champion but in the semis
miguel goes up against his friend eli
and goes for the flying tornado kick but
oh he injures himself yeah he probably
shouldn't be doing karate so soon after
a debilitating spine injury luckily it's
not his spine though just a pulled
muscle and he's cleared to fight again
if he feels up to it but he and his
sensei have not been on the same page
lately and miguel realizes that johnny
just wants to win to prove that he can
do it and so in an anticlimactic moment
miguel does not return to fight he
forfeits the boys final is not a rematch
between robbie and miguel but between
robbie and eli fighting for the opposite
dojos that they did in season one and it
is an epic karate fight yeah they are
evenly matched it comes down to a sudden
death overtime where just for fun the
shirts are coming off in the end it's
robbie keane who's gonna win but he's
distracted by the realization he might
be the bad guy now and so this time good
triumphs over evil as a redeemed hawk
eli is the boys champion but we're not
done yet kobra kai and miyagido are tied
and it all comes down to the girls match
now earlier in the tournament sam
actually looked to her brief sensei
johnny for advice and embraced his
strike first technique she's like sorry
pops i know it's not your style but i
gotta do things my way this reminds
daniel of the advice old mr miyagi gave
him and so it's time to set aside his
rivalry with johnny he makes him an
official co-sensei on this match and
make sure the announcer remembers that
johnny lawrence was also a two-time all
valley karate champion and so it's time
for the final finals yaa karate epic
fight but the referee makes some bad
calls in tory's favor and doesn't call
foul when tory accidentally elbows sam
in the face terry silver is like that's
right cobra kai is all about fighting
dirty but tori kinda wants to win
honorably and this makes john crease
think about his star student johnny
lawrence and the moment that started it
all where he forced him to fight dirty
against larusso so this time crease
makes a different decision hey kid you
don't need cheap shots to win is even
crease getting a redemption arc on this
show and this time good does not triumph
over evil because tory wins she's the
girls champion which means cobra kai is
the overall victor tori feels great
about her honorable victory but she
overhears that terry silver bribed the
ref oh her victory is now hollow now in
his victory speech terry silver
announced that cobra kai is expanding to
new locations all across the valley in
fact their new flagship dojo is going to
be at the original spot they had in the
karate kid movies they're abandoning the
rundown little strip mall location
johnny found in season one when he
restarted his cobra kai with such high
hopes to do better this time and as he's
there contemplating his defeat he gets a
visit from his son robbie who's like yo
dad i think i might have become the bad
guy and so after four seasons father and
son finally reconnect but just then
johnny's sort of son miguel needs his
help he ran off down to mexico to search
for his biological father and johnny's
gonna go after him to bring him home
safely as for daniel larusso who did
everything right but still lost and now
is supposed to shut down miyagido but
he's like look if cobra kai lost they
were definitely going to back out of the
deal so it's only fair i back out too
and he's bringing in a new co-sensei
it's chosen the villain from karate kid
2 that he befriended last season and
cobra kai is celebrating their victory
but terry silver is like you know john i
think you've been holding me back and
the cops are coming to arrest him yeah
this goes back to a minor plot with a
small returning character it's stingray
he was on probation for being a grown
man who got involved in a high school
karate brawl but now he's off probation
and ready to rejoin cobra guy but he
skipped season three where cobra kai
changed drastically and crease is like
yo you aren't welcome here so he tried
the new sensei terry silver who was in a
weird mood after a big fight with crease
and actually beat stingray up like real
bad but now we learn they made a secret
deal that he could join cobra kai if he
said it was john crease who beat him so
john kreese is going off to jail it's
the way of the sith the apprentice
always betrays the master so now darth
ponytail is the sole emperor of cobra
kai and that's where season 4 comes to
an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member